الحرب يعني وصل للخرطوم للعاصمه فمش
قادرين نتواصل مع اهالينا وفي ناس كمان من
هناك بدهم يطلعوا ويجوا وفي ناس من هون
بدهم يروحوا يعيدوا مثلا اهاليهم ما في
مجال حاليا المطار مسكر الوضع صعب النت
مسكر يعني حتى احنا طريق التواصل
بالانترنت مش عارفين نتواصل مع اهالينا
احد الذين عانوا من الحروب يعني ما جئت
الى الاردن الا بسبب الحرب وهذه الحرب انا
اعتبرها فتنه وانما يحدث ويدور الان في
السودان هو عباره عن فتنه وهذه كلها نتيجه
تراكمات سياسيه خاطئه وبالتالي الان
المتضرر الاول هو المواطن
والله بشوف الاوضاع
على الناس الشعب وربنا يحمي الوطن ويحمي
الشعب وكثير بالنسبه للطيران عنا بالاردن
كثير صعب محتاجين اشياء من السودان ما
قادرين ومحتاجين نبعث لهم ما قادرين نبعث
لازم الدوله السودانيه دوله تكون مدنيه
حره ديمقراطيه دوله برلمانيه ذات سياده
وطنيه يعني ده دشن اما التشبث والعمليات
بتاعت الانقلاب او التجارب بتاعت التجارب
بتاعت الدول السابقه فبيشوف انهينا كشعب
السوداني في الشارع يعني ما منقبل حتى ولو
يعني
العسكر استلم او سيطر او الدعم السريع
سيطر فكلاههم كل الامرين مر يعني ما في
اشي يعني ما ضافوا اشي جديد سوى الحرب
الاسلحه حاليا بتكون موجوده
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات